bet online AG or something he bend on
some crazy site
actually what else we can do Robinson's
number at six and a half does anyone
understand that
hey Duncan man yeah it's it's weird
because I think he was probably going
flying under until the last few seconds
of the game and he hit two threes like
it's scary when you when you've got a
guy who's definitely just knocking down
three he's like he can make two threes
and be done
or he could hit two threes and then make
a garbage time three like that's a
little scary to me yeah
yeah when a guy's a flamethrower six
points
it's it's and it's not like he's not
getting minutes either you know what I'm
saying like he's out there
see Lee has a a nice suggestion for us
tease up
15 and a half for Gordon
and then maybe go Caleb under five and a
half we don't have to do that now but I
think that's just a good suggestion I
agree uh 11 A.D saying bam under 11 and
a half rebounds I did see that that was
what I was gonna bring up I I mean he's
at 10 and a half so we can tease that
how do we feel depending on the number
of teasing it to 13 and a half I kind of
want to for the for the sake of things
we got going on later I I kind of don't
like this one to be honest I was
thinking that because the intern got the
bet with bam oh yeah yeah yeah I can't
do it see this is what but gunning for
the crown says Kevin Love under six and
a half boards
let me see what Kevin Love's been doing
Kevin Love is too unpredictable bro okay
so the last five he had so the last game
he had two the game before he had ten
the game before that he had zero
and then the game before that he had six
so
unpredictable it's like Ryan said
yeah what's his number uh yeah I I
should have done that four and a half
see the thing is God damn it the thing
is
Kevin Love can go out there and do
nothing but rebound all game today
and we'll be screwed
that is true yeah he scored last game
didn't rebound last game like I could
easily see him not scoring this game and
rebounding and rebound
literally well the thing is though I
mean I agree with you Greg I think it's
right but they have to score more points
than they did last game or they're not
going to even be close like if they need
to get they need to get this win
desperately or else they're getting you
know this will be over in five like I
kind of see his minutes going down maybe
like he's not great offensively they
need to score buckets man I feel like it
might be close so if we think it's close
let's just skip it because I don't want
to be the guy that did that but yeah I
think it's a solid look and shout out to
gunning for the crown who said Kevin
Love under six and a half boards I would
I would like to tease it up I would but
he he has too many games where it's like
eight nine ten
I don't even feel good teasing and yeah
and and he just came here in the chat
came back in the chat he's like yeah
y'all right he is definitely
unpredictable yeah I mean we're all
saying the same thing all right Ryan how
about this why don't we go under 15 and
a half for Gordon as we find the next
pick okay we'll move it around a little
bit
um
uh there's somebody else who elbe El
Bay's got a good comment here I did see
that what about Jamal and that Court
burn
[Music]
but yeah the thing looked like it was
bubbling up like it had all type of
all type of all type of fluids in there
or something yeah it was nasty it was
nasty
but you know like they're gonna wrap it
it's it's offhand he'll probably have
some tape on it
I don't know how much it'll affect them
but that thing looked nasty for sure all
right we got Jesus definitely going to
be passing a lot we know Jamal Murray is
going to be passing line
so we might want to stay away from
kcp under assists
what are we doing
no regard for your narrative on the game
I'm just reading the game bro you can't
be mad at my you told me to analyze so
when I started why did I say that what
did I say analyze Greg like four weeks
ago maybe you remember four weeks ago if
I said that I said it's sitting in my
brain right there in my memory like you
know where we remember things in your
brain it's like first thing oh God
Ryan is so sad right now I should
believe it try the try the kcp under
assists all right
he's not even on the board either
all right well I didn't want this is
Thomas Ryan I know we talked about this
but
what's the game total bro
I thought we were going somewhere else
uh yeah I thought we were going to Mom
Murray under two
it's too low I can't I Can't Sweat
another bet with the game the Gable in
there that was hell
as hell
211 211. can you bet can we bet under
threes made
like in the game
yeah
I don't know
this is tough man yeah this is a lot
harder than last time how did we get how
did that happen
stuff aren't you going with Jamal and
Murray's under
I am but I thought we were well we were
teasing it we're gonna get I saw it on
social I'm sorry it's the head yeah yeah
but
Dave Vincent under assists
I got some I got some data for you too
okay I was gonna say we need data I
can't all right three and a half oh it's
three and a half
the last game he had zero the game
before he had three game before that he
had five game for that he had four
it's tough
assistant that to me what are we what
are we talking two on and two on we're
on we're riding the two off right
yeah yeah
I don't think we can do
we can
oh KJ Mullins mpj under threes let's
let's take a look
man's been breaking them uh my uh
what is it it's one and a half it's
under one and a half what's going on
here what are they on with us bro we're
too sharp
Murray made it difficult
good call three and a half how is he
yeah what a messed up hand and he's
gonna be passing the ball
yeah
what stop saying that
I just want to be on the right side bro
El bay El Bay saying under jokic threes
uh give us any value though no mine is
250. minus 215. KJ Mullins who's this
heat Whisperer uh Jimmy under rebounds
elbe Jimmy under assists
I don't usually like to double dip on
the
on my props no let's not double dip
but it's not double dip but Jimmy under
assists is that what you just said yeah
I was saying I don't want to double dip
because I did that last yeah yeah I
don't I don't trust that that's gonna
happen again but uh he said Jimmy under
rebounds is what KJ Mullins said
um
where did I skip it yeah I did uh six
and a half thoughts while I try and find
some data to back that up
all right what is it six and a half
rebounds yeah you got two four seven ten
and six in the last five against the
nuggets
down there bro he's not making it up
down there now
I don't think I think so he didn't do it
last game but but
you hear me hear me out
he didn't do it last game right so do
you not think he's gonna make the
adjustments this game
I don't know I just feel like it's just
too clogged in there like I don't think
it's necessarily how much he wants the
rebounds like you were saying about
um about Caleb Martin I just feel like
there's not a lot of opportunities when
you're when you've got bam and jokish
down there
yeah plus like everyone's forcing him to
shoot like he don't want him to get into
the lane so he's keeping them outside
they won game two with him only getting
four rebounds too so they can win with
him only you know rebounding at a
minimal number
so I I mean we're over plus 400. I like
it
I like it
you look a little nervous bro yeah like
when you look nervous well because Jimmy
always scared he looks nervous every
show yeah but Jimmy has like these these
trends that you can follow
uh
I'm not saying I'm nada I just I
there's not a tread to support this is
what I'm trying to say I like betting
against Jimmy when there's a trend to
follow not when there's Vibes to follow
now if KJ Mullins jumps in this chat
right now and tells me on a scale of one
to ten he's a 14 and he's confident that
he's that confident I'll ride that all
day but he just dropped it and I don't
see the guy so I don't I mean
tell us go ahead what about Lowry's
under points
that comes from
G Smith 813
C
what is it what is it what is let's take
a look at it
eight and a half
okay in his last five against the
Nuggets 9 9 11 3 and 17.
and the so the three and the 17 are
farther away
right oh I love that I I mainly because
he's hit the over like every single time
also also while we while we stew on it
bagel and locks with a scoop Jimmy under
one and a half steals he's gone under
this number in every Finals game last
deal was game one
uh we're about to find out uh it's still
not gonna be enough with the Lowry so
let's let's hope this this is I'm not
gonna lie we could get Lowry to 10
points I don't see him scoring 10 points
no we can't same game parlay steals so
that's unfortunate but uh
damn
can't parliamder let's just go with the
boards bro which one
yeah I felt good about that not gonna
lie
I'm trying to figure out what like I
need the chat to be more specific and
direct as to what they're saying Jim
Butler are going to be moving the ball
around six and a half rebounds is not
safe but what is it is it good for us or
not good for us what is not safe for me
I didn't think about that like hold on
this is very important because we need
to hit this one again yeah uh I I do
like this though uh I I will say that I
I enjoy this one
um the butler done for the crown came in
late
he's saying Michael Porter Jr under 14
and a half not gonna do it tonight's the
night he goes nuclear I think yeah yeah
I really believe that
yeah I think he's just very much like a
streaky shooter and he's on a bad streak
but for him to have three bad shooting
nights in a row
I don't know man these guys are too good
for all that yeah
all right yeah
unless we go like under 20 points which
ain't gonna be any value so let's lock
this in man let's we got it we gotta oh
man all right let's do it
you sound so nervous Ryan I yeah I just
like I this yeah yeah yeah well there
just like wasn't enough like we didn't
last time I felt like we looked at the
board and we were like bingo bango bongo
and tonight we we did a lot of hemming
and hawing but let's listen man it this
is just this is like a game of chess man
some days you get the Right Moves some
days you gotta find the Right Moves Like
I don't think these are bad plays
you're gonna have to give us a pep talk
at the end of the show man because I
don't like your Vibes right now I just
don't all right I gotta
it's okay we're gonna get your stuff
let's lock it in let's lock it in let's
lock it in Ryan while we're locking it
in you know and while I have you review
it one more time let's get the Vibes
right now
let's try to get the Vibes right Caleb
Martin under six and a half rebounds
Aaron Gordon under 15 and a half points
again an alternate total there is no
sports book out there that is offering
Aaron Gordon's regular line at 15.
Jamal Murray under three and a half made
threes with the floor burned hand and
then Jimmy Butler under six and a half
rebounds four legs plus four zero five
uh let's make it two in a row shall we
shout out let's do it let's get it boys
let's do it let's do it let's lock it in
man if you want to tell our Park our
parlay make sure you head on over to
FanDuel
but when you go do that Ryan tell the
people what's up for the new customers
yeah for the new guys and gals uh
go over to FanDuel you bet five dollars
and you got 150 in bonus bets guaranteed
and I can't stress this enough I really
can't I do not care what you do with 150
I don't but it's yours it's yours it's
guaranteed and it'll be yours and you
can do whatever you want with it but 150
uh in bonus bets guaranteed if you bet
five dollars and your new customer
FanDuel
[Music]
all right it's time for Best Bets time
for Best Bets Ryan you're gonna lead off
bowling you go second I'll go third Ryan
talk to me talk to the people what do
you like as your best bet for today all
right dude so last time that I was
batting lead off we got on base right I
said I was gonna get on base and I got
on base
we've hit five of these fate superstars
in a row five 3-0 in the finals
I cannot express to you guys
how much I love
Jamal Murray under seven and a half
assists I know Greg he's gonna pass
let's go and the next thing
he has 10 assists in his last three
games now you may think oh Mike Eddie
leads the finals and assist by the way
bad beat for people who bet jokic at
minus twenty thousand you may think he's
going he's been passing he's just gonna
keep going over he's gonna keep going
over well let me tell you dude Jamal
Murray this season he has played many
basketball games and many minutes he has
gone over this total in two straight
games he's gone over this total in three
straight games several times not one
time all year not one time all year has
he gone over this total in four straight
games I love the under tonight I I love
why would he listen if we're gonna I
don't even want to say the L word I was
I'm not even gonna say the L word
because it's not gonna happen but
what this would be an outlier to an
outrageous extent it's it's
seven and a half take the under trust me
we'll make it six straight The Fading
Superstars tread baby 14 and six I've
Juiced up God ready to go I'm ready to
go
somebody bring me home somebody bring me
home I felt like a gapper
my man Ryan let's go is rocking with
Jamal Murray under seven and a half
assists
MB you're next what do we rocking with
what's the best bet
man I'm just as fired up as Ryan man and
I think I'm fired up mostly because of
the 100 approval rating of one intern
John if you are not aware of the legend
of intern John
get in the app get on social and figure
it out so I am tailing graciously his
play tonight bam and jokic combined for
24 boards
it's pretty simple man I don't really
even need to get into it too much bam is
playing at the level that everyone
expects him to play and everyone
expected him to play when he was drafted
and put into this lineup he's grabbing
boards he's scoring points and then you
have the two-time MVP should have been
three-time MVP if we're being honest
he had 20 boards last game even if he
gets 15 boards that would give you over
half of this total if you don't think
jokic is getting 15 and Bam is getting
at least 10. I don't know what kind I
don't know what I don't know what you're
drinking but
I'm drinking what I'm drinking and I
think that this is an absolute Stone
Cold lead pipe quad diamond lock
all right my man MB is rocking with the
intern and turn John and going with Adam
bio and my Manny jokish to combine for
24 rebounds or more
two rabbits are on base and it's my turn
to bring them in
I had a mask dude if you guys go and be
our bedding if you guys go on our social
platforms you'll see me interviewing a
mask dude today
I had a mass dude on earlier and um
he told me he straight up told me that
he he he Fades me like I've been having
a terrible playoff run and he told me
that he's made a lot of money going the
opposite way of me so
I asked him for a play I asked him I'm
like okay well since you're the sharp
since you're the guru here uh what's the
play tonight he said okay Greg I got you
bam autobio under 35 and a half points
rebounds and assist
that's what he told me to to bet he says
he's a professional he says he's a guru
he says that he made money fading me so
guess what I'm gonna put my faith into
him and if he loses I'm fading him the
rest of 2023 guaranteed and we're gonna
see who's the recipe God or not the rest
of 2023
you better hope this dude doesn't go on
a heater dude that could that's for the
rest of the Year ah nah screw that Ryan
I rest the 2023.
they say they make money off of me okay
I want to return the flavor I want to
start dating other people
you return to the flavor
whatever favor you get the picture they
will too once I start fading
I'm with it I I again I love the energy
as well that's just a long time people's
been telling me they've been in my DMC
they've been fading me for four years
and they're very profitable
I don't know if I believe that either
I'll be honest but yeah
so so I'm gonna start fading these
people this guy if he doesn't hit I'm
fading them for the rest of the year and
we're gonna told we're gonna tally this
up next year's in NBA show we're gonna
run this back and I'll let you guys know
if this guy led me to the promised land
or not
but that's only that only happens that
only happens if he loses tonight
so if he wins he's a guru
let's go
I'm gonna hop Here We Done Quick I'm
seeing some I've seen some comments
about first basket
for people who haven't seen just yet I'm
going back to the well with bam
plus 650 last I checked might have lost
some value and I'm going with Aaron
Gordon
plus plus a thousand last I checked
listen
bam he might be my best friend at this
point so we'll just have to figure he
might be my cousin you know Greg you
know how you you fight with your cousins
every once in a while but like you
really homies after everything like
that's how I feel about bam that's
family and Aaron Gordon is just kind of
like a long shot he had he had an
attempt to start last game he just got
fouled so we'll see but I'm going back
to the well with bam that's where I put
my money at
there it is you guys got mb's first
basket place right here on the bleacher
report app uh that's it man that's it uh
Ryan do you want to go over the far away
I know we just have it pop up I never do
but I will however there it is uh there
it is Kayla Martin under six and a half
rebounds Aaron Gordon under 15 and a
half points Jamal Murray under three and
a half threes and Jimmy Butler under six
and a half rebounds
make sure you guys screenshot I really
want to wear glasses again next week so
let's get this man that would be fun
right now yeah let's get this W all
right guys uh my name is Greg ivory
above me right now is the man we like to
call producer Ryan he's to the left now
there he is he said hello right you just
be moving all over the place bro you
gotta stay still yeah well you're hot
you're just all over the place huh I say
you got it
hey until you're right and I like the
color MB you guys might know him as
Michael bowler he is the man of the app
we are out of here
peace
[Music]
[Applause]